and scoot down more that
way both
teams don't overturn your stay oriented
towards her don't don't Orient towards
the weapon
make sure you're in my on the
Kissa fix your posture you're already
filled the tension get off the back hill
you're you're you're neutral now dynamic
if the m is right on the Kessa then one
entry from Hani to K on the Oshi Zuki
you your Joe should penetrate through
the full
body so the UK who isn't feeling the
pressure is probably not in the right
place for the mai or the nag moved too
far out of range and probably isn't
hitting the hands or the center on the
atoshi okay but the my is off try it
again my's part of the form
all right so what I said made no change
on your Technique okay so do you
understand what I
said hi I'm too far
out on the
ski what is your symptom for that the
fact that I'm extended on the final move
I'm really extended almost overextended
and and I'm barely touching Chris okay
penetrated and
then that's that's the final symptom
what is the cause I gave you a
couple someone else I want you to
demonstrate that you understood what I
said because you didn't put it into
practice right so before
I
think you're trying to [\h__\h] with me I
want to make sure you understood what I
said and it's just not out of
ignorance okay so he's right I did say
that and I gave some possible causes for
that to most likely Virginia what's one
of them on
the um to keep the correct mind too far
back when the
comes okay so the Kessa is out of
range do you guys understand that okay
so now the my is off already you if the
Kessa is out of range you wouldn't
attack the hands do do you understand
that was like no you got to be in range
to make the hands as a Target makes
sense okay so you have your part to do
in the
set um what are some of the things that
make the Kessa out of
range there's an obvious one
what yeah you're in you're in yokan Joe
yokan do you understand and you're not
doing the actual Kessa so the arms are
uh more extended the hands are at
shoulder height um your back foot is out
there you're trying to end this freaking
fight immediately so this is like
infighting Kessa infighting yokomen so
the way we've done yokomen from inside
the the uh collar tie with the bicep
hold right inside the clinch it's a very
anchored elbow and it's from do you uh
shman but turn your wrist at the end
okay so the hands are lower than
shoulder height and the relationship
between the tip of the Sword and the
goup of the sword is way more
vertical does does that make sense okay
but even if that
was the problem of course is is the
problem it is fixed by
what checking with
the and not allowing uh the subsequent
move to enter
freely uh you mean the Joe right on the
Joe yeah so if you if you hit the hands
and you bring the hands into the center
the the ve Vector that Oshi on the hands
so that it vectors through the center
and not just straight down on the hand
hands you're going to be close enough
it's going to be the same distance and
then the atoshi Zuki Works do you get
that so they messed up they changed your
mind you should adapt to their
mind okay you don't take the E don't
just do the form here in air quotes and
that's prioritized over what's the
relationship they change the form you
change the form okay so you still have
to meet the requirements of the form the
concept so when I hit the hands I have
to hit the
center I can't be so far away
from how I hit their hands that the
vector I have is nowhere near their
Center I'm just pulling down on their
hands okay if you pay attention while
you're not able to penetrate on the
atoshi Zuki
Sean he also has a very free Center he's
just standing there which I'm not in his
Center okay um and then what's the other
obvious reason why someone's Kessa might
be out of range it's so don't over
complicate
it too yeah they're just too far they're
just sticking their weapon out in the
middle of the fight and not trying to
hit the target okay so when you're that
roll the sword make sure you're fixing
these things and then when you're the
Joe make sure you're doing the Yoshi
correctly conceptually correctly yes I
attack the wrist but my vectors through
their Center I'm pinning their Center
weight is being driven down onto their
midfoot okay got got that all right and
then we should meet in the middle
regardless of what people are doing okay
all right let's go
there you go and spear his ass let's get
a little more Athletics
[Music]
here this is not the intro day yesterday
was intro day let's [\h__\h] train
you got to pin that Center he you
Virginia you're hooking
it so the more if you go if you over
rotate the cross there's less vertical
pressure do you see um and so now the
center is not down now they don't remain
as close now they're able to move okay
so careful that you're not hooking that
thing go
again you got the
correction
better drop your Chi you have a lot of
tension in your lower leg so it didn't
drop past the Joe
lot of
tension not much a tush you have to feel
his Center and you then you have to drop
through
it and if you can't take a chemy then
you can't do the you can't do that
nogget Maya okay do you understand so
did you tell her whether you're taking
kimy or not
Virginia okay so you can't do it you're
going to have to lighten everything
lengthen
everything and just walk out rather than
Virginia she's not dropping your Center
you're going to keep your movability
just walk out so you're not stressing
your knee more by walking bent backwards
just walk
out don't be there waiting for the Joe
fill the face with the Joe end
same thing
um continuous motion the symbol for
continuous motion is is figure
okay uh it's also your Al and your immer
spirals put you put them together and
it's that movement that we always do in
ik you see it all the time and it is in
the middle of your dojo Crest you have
the heart this way but this way you have
the figure
a I'm trying to tell you it's
Central um the say is where linear end
circular BS and where circular ends
linear begins so linear and circular
begin
circular ends linear begins do you see
that okay what it is is it's not reverse
motion it's not right angle
motion
okay um it allows you to get a lot of
power because you're transferring
momentum from one angle into the other
angle okay so for example the guys
up and hold the sword in the other hand
and say he has a a punch okay and I want
to hit this back knuckle well that's
really short it's really short but if I
start from the Parry it's one big wind
up this way it's it would be like I do
this you see so and I come in this way
and I start lengthening the path of
action you see and I can build up more
speed transfer momentum Etc if you your
sort out it would be the same thing if
I'm here like
this I've lengthened the path of action
and I can start building up more
energy so on this
technique when he goes around and that's
reverse motion you see and now there's
only so much I get there okay there only
so much because it's a very short path
of action it's very powerful because of
how much mass is in there right but it
doesn't have that lengthen passive
action so uh you're just going to be a a
Target okay instead of uh going like
this you're winding up you see
that coming in okay not here like that
you see that difference okay so that's
what's in
here it's one big wind up
so when you come here that's a zigzag
that's one short wind
up is where that comes you guys see that
okay so I if I trace the parts that's
where that is going to be which gives me
other tactical priorities being met and
I come
around is my wind up you see that so we
should see
that that Joe in his face on the center
line occupying it we should not see here
you see that that's going be very weak I
know it feels strong but it's nowhere
near somebody who wound up and did the
same uh Mass equation or mass value in
that they're they're adding way more
speed into that uh Force equation okay
so let's try
different there's no my turn your
turn you're on the whole time
[Applause]
yes and now you still do Theos you
didn't pin
him again at a certain point we you just
got to have you just thrust on him okay
he'll learn he knows how to [\h__\h] fall
are you are do you have red tape on your
knee Chris no s okay then [\h__\h] spear
his [\h__\h] ass because the teacher said
we already introduced the form let's
[\h__\h] train
make sure there's no rotational energy
when you
SK you you have to hit the linear
line well before you make
[Applause]
contact see that that's not you're
turning
it vertical on then in
same thing you're turning it in
range you did the push okay and then
you're going to hit the target right and
the target's going to offer some
resistance okay got it so as you're
you're trying to bring it up to your
head and you're going to have that curve
there you see that and you hit that
Target on the curve part it's going to
have leverage over you so as you is
pressing and as you keep going it's
taking your tip offline you see that so
you will go all the way up
first yeah yes do that normal please
just go up and now get your body in
alignment and now you hit your body is
the horse and this is your Jou okay and
you spear him with your horse driving
through him boom that's what you want
okay so you can't you can't go here and
be turning it on them you see it kept it
out I have to be get
position and then Jou boom there's no
rotational
torque after I touch their person that
means all rotational torque has to end
before I start to in okay don't get lazy
try it
again if you Spar them like I'm asking
you you would learn these
things
go is I'm not talking speed I'm talking
fullness of
motion fullness of
being you can choose either one you want
to work I want to work your push or I
want to work the ski just don't do them
above because your knee is not going to
take it you get it I probably work your
tush
you got to get that
dropped it's barely any
pen don't bring the hand up
the hand up that's why the tips is
dropping that's why it's actually
lighter finish the
push your tips
down the only way the tip is down is if
your hand is up do you understand that
and if my right hand is up the Joe's not
heavy yes and I'm over rotate the cross
which we already noted
before okay so there's there's mechanics
here that you have to follow okay so you
can't go like that all right do you see
that so I dropped a tip when my hand is
higher you see so that was supposed to
go here okay so here I am like that and
I want to go like this
okay I'm also not going to do something
weird the the energy drops with the
intern internal dropping so I can't have
tension in my body I can't be parallel
that the energy
drops okay and you can see and you can
feel how his feet got [\h__\h] up okay got
it and that's not with
the extended path of action okay so it's
no different than we're we're here right
and I'm
like I'm just doing that same thing
whatever that is
or this
here that power do you see is in this
same
thing what you're doing is you're going
to your external power sources is that's
not as powerful
okay again back to my other comment Bo
I'm not going quick but I'm going
correctly and full
okay try it
again this kind of like yesterday Chris
how I
said once I feel your pressure on your
hand and I feel the RoR to my foot the
drill is done for me same thing here
once I feel your feet I push through put
the weight on there I don't have
to totally do it you see that's that's
the difference I
think um I'm working at the energetic
level allows me to train safely
purposefully consciously get all the
internal
okay so don't confuse what I'm saying
with going crazy now you're doing weird
[\h__\h] and uh it's just the thing is that
some of you won't get your being into it
unless you're going full speed but now
we have the other problem it's the wrong
okay right switchs
you to feel his feet
sh you feel your your young aspect on
your
midfoot if you feel her feet you
wouldn't Point your tip down you're
going too early into the the aosi Zuki
so you're lifting the back hand way too
early you want to feel her feet you want
to push her feet
[Music]
down so the say is where linear and
circular begins I got that
okay so in that in that pattern you're
going to see straight lines that's a
straight line you see that and then you
come around that's a curve there's
nothing straight about it and then
that's a straight line there's nothing
curved about it okay so when when you
when you make like two circles do you
see that that's not it okay so here I
have curves
then it
ends straight down there's nothing
curved about it
don't curve it it's not a curve okay so
you have to
complete the
linearity boom and then it's a new move
here it's not this move coming like that
do you guys get that um Mr Pig you say
you have to complete the cycle of action
it was a pistol reference you [\h__\h] up
the cycle of action the Gun starts to
malfunction so something similar to this
is like you have to wait for the click
if I'm loading the magazine I got to go
click right I don't and then start
getting my grip the magazine falls out
or didn't see properly so it has to go
linear to the clip then you can start
getting your grip you see so same thing
it has to go linear
till the feet they're there boom there's
the pin then it comes up it doesn't go
into this move okay try again
you're bringing it up
good now get your back foot in place
don't let your arch cave you have your
own young aspect to address
slide down the book
in don't poke with your hands right
you're the jousting your horse hits
him yeah not even close right Chris no
weight on the
that's why I said you should work on the
atoshi with Virginia and not the
ski don't poke with the hands you're so
[\h__\h] tiny do you understand I'll let
you hit me with your hands all day long
you're not going to hurt me I could have
laughing and just grab that Joe out of
your hands like a little child but you
hit me with your body it's 100 plus PBS
you got something there okay drop 100 lb
on my chest that's going to [\h__\h]
hurt okay
go ahead and enter it's time to do
it use your
height you keep sparing with your hands
just hold it right here hold it here
look stop doing this just hold
it got to finish that circle before you
enter
keep spearing you're giving Meo in your
own hand on the
back come on
breathe don't you keep giving nikel on
your hand on the top when you hit the
target it's going to bounce out of your
hand
come on feel the feet don't do the form
feel the
feet two moves don't slur the linear
feel the feet feel the
okay so let's do some Discovery learning
on this you don't need
your okay so your your grip has to be
able to hold it it's fine you're just a
Target he's just Mass he's resistance
okay so you want a hammer
grip as much as possible you see that if
you start doing this it's hard for the
fingers to close which is why we use
these wrist locks to disarm any weapon
you're hold so this this is technically
n you see that which will happen if you
drive forward you see how it's happening
stay there Chris don't move here I am I
have a straight wrist I have a hammer
grip and I start to drive forward you
see how the wrist angle is going you
have KN your going that thing is going
to pop out of your hands okay so the
same thing is here right and when I get
this wrist going here you'll see it's
getting compromised where I hold a
hammer Gip you can do that all day okay
so when you're here like
that you hold the hammer
rip and your body Hammer rip and your
body moves
don't push with your arms you shouldn't
feel it in your
arms here ground on the back foot move
the back
foot boom keep the hammer grip
boom don't push
come
on you can walk out of this there's no P
you don't have to take
the just be
M you lose your balance as you will be
accelerated take the fall don't break
your head
good
jot if you pay attention with the hammer
grip your grip does not have to be all
that tight
[Music]
don't fall onto the front foot keep
going as well work on the Mii ground the
back foot the bra mid foot and use the
back
glute to don't fall on that
foot push through on
that don't use your on the
back Hammer GP on both so that means
straight wrist straight wrist
try not to fall into the stance you're
pushing into the
stance use your back right
glue drive into the stance
try not to fall into so this is
falling this is
pushing
push
fall different okay next
drill no joke two of you and you're two
twice the mass got
it same thing
here I go like this I'm not going
anywhere okay can't fall into
that same right angle round the back
foot you can see my grips not death grip
and I drive the back
foot okay let's
try let's go three
just standing you're not doing anything
you just Twice The Mask make sure you're
smashed when you see falling what do you
think don't come
up better don't let your hands go okay
so see that's one of the those things
like everything works when you're not
testing it you know what I mean so you
could do the
falling right but you should know
kinesiologic that's just not right we've
had
many demonstrations on how to do aashi
how to do sui and you can't fall into it
there's no way
okay um or you can just try really
freaking hard and actually try to hurt
someone and that dude got right the [\h__\h]
back up that's the clue you get it you
should not get right back up after I
gave my 110% through his chest that
should have been the end of it so it
would be no different that I shoot a
particular caliber and the dude got back
up I'm like okay I'm not using 22s
anymore do you understand do you get it
you guys get that you don't want to go I
just need to use these 22s better now I
[\h__\h] use them to their maximum
ability and it didn't didn't work okay
very similar mindset okay so let's keep
going we'll do uh three reps
each be in the middle of the
M we're doing the pushing exercise yeah
yep we're going to do it again move
towards the middle of the
mat lock your body the same internal
structuring organization
you're trying to go up and fall you got
to push
straight push straight there you go good
just keep telling yourself that push
straight one more
rep push straight don't fall don't seek
height and then
fall push straight lower lower lock your
body push straight push straight you
keep raising that foot you're going to
go
up that's all
three we can just use the
same it doesn't
matter if it's hurting the person in
front just go to the back okay
okay first let's put that right hand
over our head not behind our
head okay right and then lower your
stance so you don't go up right and then
drive from the right midfoot through the
right glute keep your organization don't
come up don't come up push with your
legs that's
it so you can feel the difference when
you start to see kite you're not going
anywhere
got two more reps to not seek height
right no don't let that go behind your
head you'll start to get another wrist
angle not the hammer grip top of your
head it stays
there keep pushing that's it
careful one more
lower don't twist keep
organization okay cycle
through lower lower you already you
already have that weak hinge at the top
of the qua into the abdomen we talked
about that yesterday on the shman you
you can't do that if you have a positive
can in your torso your upper body you
will lock that quad line
okay let's see how it's bending back on
you
so it might seem can you guys
all it might seem like uh she's smaller
but this this this is this is
nothing you understand this this doesn't
really take take any effort you're just
going to move move feel that move move
move move move move do you understand so
you can hear my voice I'm not
going okay got it so it's this is
plenty reasonable mass for your side
because I think I was feeling like I
don't
know maybe 5 lbs of
pressure no it already broke the quadw
line on top do you understand what I
mean by that this line this line right
here you have a you have a hinge that
you cannot have okay so that's why you
had that weakness when we were pushing
on the chest yesterday okay so no keep
this hand still in space don't let it go
back I would you come forward on your
spine now it's long so keep that and get
rid of the N
Hammer
grip now you have to you guys move
forward you don't need to pin it on your
sh on your head it's just there and you
move from this glute through this mid
foot there you
go but now you have to do it without my
touch right
the hands going back the hand went back
if the hands going back you're pushing
on the
hand coming up stretching your hands
come on one
more it seems like an innocent thing
that I said it seems so innocent I know
stop for a second it seems so
trivial that I can come over touch your
body and then organize your body it's
like it's so
like I do you do you get it but it was
effortless on that rep post touch
there's things that you're that you're
missing one is that he came over and he
touched her and organized her body and
the movement became
effortless that's the first thing the
second thing is that you dby therefore
have the capacity within you that's the
second thing you're not noticing and
then the third thing is you're not
noticing how your capacity is still
dependent upon my touch my manipulation
of you that that can't be okay do you
guys understand that that that's not
your practice that's my practice again
so my practice I can come over now and
touch you and fix you that's my practice
that's not your practice got it so the
more [\h__\h]
up you are such that you require that
touch the better my practice and the
more that I fix you how [\h__\h] up you
may be the better my practice but but
the more you need me to fix you and the
more [\h__\h] up you are to increase the
need the worse your practice do you guys
understand that so don't confuse that
when I fix you and you do it that you're
doing it it's actually worse for you
okay so what I would do is try to feel
my touch again that's where I would go
imagine my hand on your chest got got it
imagine where I positioned your top half
okay try it
again feel the
touch don't think feel
much
better
psycho okay you had some twist there so
lock your horizontal claw lines
okay now start believing it's effortless
okay that is me touching her
thought you believe it's effortless it
should be effortless as I
demonstrated one more believe
better where you feel the the pressure
release that pressure
don't keep pushing against that
pressure better okay all right that
comes into the form go
two
more you're sling too much your tou is
to
curve thank to curve and not in her feet
at
all no don't fall for no reason that
would that's not what we're
doing you fall so you don't get hurt
with the deadly SK you see her feet are
not
pin don't point the tip
down two each that's
it I don't oh Sean that look like a very
light
atush you're holding your breath I don't
know how the Cheese's going to
draw right will stop there